do your kids like when you do the Olaf
voice though they hate it the Olaf voice
is the this is the voice right so they
like I tried for a while reading them
like frozen books and like I thought it
was so cool even though I do a horrible
on an Elsa but they were just over they
didn't want it anymore so I started
reading the Harry Potter books at their
school so every Friday I go in and I did
I read I read all the book one last year
to the kids I read all of booktube but
spoiler alert guess which two children
refused to come to the readings because
you're the dad right yeah so I will be
sitting in front of like a group of 40
children all their friends and they'll
like walk in with their book bags and be
like hey Dad you good we're just gonna
go play back there I'm like I'm this was
firk bonding I'm not getting paid for
this but that's gonna be amazing for
them they'll be amazed at what you would
think no I mean the other kids as well
so have you come and do that that's
amazing oh it's great and they pay me
under the table so it makes it all those
kids pay me under the day and like
skittles your lunch money and I'll take
your lunch money I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this